[Music]
uh right welcome to gourmet estate here
in baltimore at the amazing horseshoe
i'm about to surprise um four talented
college students they think they're in a
competition
i have no idea that i'm here to judge
them today so have to be super quiet
but the good news is it's gonna be a
little surprise so um
i can't wait to see what they're gonna
cook they've got half an hour mystery
box
so they're um they've just started
and they're about to get the shock of
their lives
here we go
thank you so much good to see tom
uh my goodness me um let's just say the
students are doing well right
it looks good it looks fast and good
four individuals four very strong
individuals um
sadly there's only one first place
[Applause]
it is a stakeoff okay bad luck so i've
got the stakes out at room temperature
rib eye
i use this uh a lot because of the
marbling of the fat okay so let's think
around a great rib eye is in the
coloring called a rib eye because this
this eye in the middle here is like the
sort of
the chest piece and this rib cap here is
the bit that is
absolutely delicious okay so first thing
we're going to do lift up the steak
and just season the tray okay
salt and pepper quite generously because
we'll lose 30 of that before
actually goes in to the pan then lay the
steak on top
good and then again a nice salt and
pepper again now it looks like we're
putting a lot of seasoning on there but
like i said we lose a lot of it and then
what i'd like to do then from there
is roll it round and literally mop up
that seasoning
now sometimes you can have a beautiful
ancho chili rub a coffee rub it goes so
well with ribeye
yeah then i get the fat side down the
chain underneath there
and i also mop that up as well i hate
waste
right i want to use all that seasoning
now that steak is done
and beautifully seasoned all the way
around yes just really from there
towel in the hand pan nice and hot
okay i'm gonna start with a touch of oil
in there first so the butter
doesn't burn oil into the pan
and then the pan goes straight in about
a tablespoon first when you put the
steak in
lay it away from you okay straight down
always away
there you go good now from there
literally lift that up and just make
sure that's not sticking
great as that's caramelizing
you can see that it's not that fast it
smells really good
from there i'm going to pick up my thyme
okay
i'll put my aromats in there now stick
my thyme on top
and my garlic in there okay and now i'm
going to start off with the
sort of normal butter just down to the
sides
and you'll see that absolutely go into a
nice nut brown
beautiful color from there
lift up the steak and turn that over
again
there you go and again lay away
so it all stops the button from burning
very carefully lift up
flat side down and sear that fat
underneath that chain
that's all edible there and the more fat
we render the flavor
profile of that steak and get better and
better now from there
keep it really nice and hot i'm gonna go
with the truffle butter in mine
i'm gonna take some truffle butter in
and then put it down to the sides
take a spoon okay and lift it carefully
push the steak up
i'm gonna baste my steak with that
truffle butter and
literally push it to the side and now
what we're doing now is making that
steak even more tender
so the fats render down inside we've got
this beautiful caramelization
i'm not just almost like spooning it
over
three and a half four minutes max two
minutes on each side and then from there
take it out and let it rest now one
final turn hold it up again
and turn it around very carefully good
now i'm going to go to medium rare okay
that means i'm going to take it out of
the pan
rare and come off with my gas
straight off with that i'm gonna lift up
my stage
first presentation side up and literally
lift that up over there i'm gonna put on
my arrow mats over the top let that sit
okay yeah beautiful
and then finally something that you'd
recognize
[Music]
absolutely
i can guarantee you next time you've got
a barbecue at home trust me
you're gonna be grilling a rib eye good
job sam everybody
appreciate it thank you great job great
[Music]
hello baltimore it's guy fury here happy
mother's day
don't look good slim hello baltimore
it is bobby flay here wishing you all a
very happy mother's day
yes you didn't know as english but [ __ ]
me can i cook
next